so welcome to this free webinar on
rna sequencing for infectious diseases
today's session will introduce you to
the rna-seq data analysis
and the upcoming online training program
this training will include methods of
machine learning for bulk
and single cell gene expression studies
special focus on examples from
infectious disease
research such as malaria and covert 19
disease progression
immunology and biomarkers
the upcoming omics logic program
called omex logic transcriptomics
starting on april 16th
will be focused on how we can leverage
rnac to study infectious disease
from the perspective of host responses
disease progression and host pathogen
interaction one of the major focus
will be on the application of
bioinformatics to malaria related
research
where we will be looking at efficacy of
vaccines and drugs
associated with resistance and the
complexity of
host pathogen vector interaction for
this purpose our team has already
prepared
a number of research data repositories
and databases that will help
participants identify high
impact data sets for analysis we will
also discuss
various applications of genomics to the
study of source cov2
where selective pressure on various
proteins will lead to the emergence of
new variants
such changes are already being seen
as a result of increased immunity
vaccination and other host pathogen
dynamics
at pine biotech our mission is to
simplify bioinformatics for students
clinicians and biologists and we do
this through our training programs known
as
omixlogic the omixlogic bioinformatics
training programs are running in five
different regions with over 10
000 users all over the world
our training is designed to allow
participants to apply methods
to curated and new data sets and develop
independent projects that
showcase what has been learned in the
context of a personal portfolio
of projects as a result anyone starting
on
this journey in bioinformatics can start
developing
a project of their own in fact we have
already worked with many students who
have completed this kind of training and
developed interesting research projects
that won
awards and got published in
peer-reviewed
journals these are some of those project
examples
and to achieve this goal we use a
combination of online sessions like we
are having today self-guided study
materials which i will be introducing
you to
shortly and practical assignments for an
immersive experience that has proven to
be effective
in our well-known and respected omics
logic programs
so in the upcoming one month period you
will have the opportunity to
interact and collaborate with an
international team of experts
specialized in the areas of
bioinformatics
and data driven research let me
introduce you to the program
mentors we will have dr harpreet kaur
who is our omics logic trainer and
expert bioinformatician
she will mentor sessions and guide
participants through the program
her area of specialization is in cancer
genomics
dr mohit mazumdar has a phd in
computational biology and over 10 years
of experience working with industry and
academia
he will also guide the project sessions
and offer
his expert advice on student projects
elia prosky is our ceo and co-founder
his experience in research in academia
has led
to many research labs and university
collaboration
has been recognized for the simplified
approach to omics analysis for education
now i would like to invite elia to talk
more about
transcriptomics for infectious diseases
over to you ilia
thank you very much bipsay and welcome
everyone to this
webinar i'm uh
going to just uh share my screen here
so as big to mention my name is ilya
brodsky and what i want to do in this
part of this session
is to introduce you to some of the
topics that we will be covering in this
program and share a little perspective
on rna-seq in the context of infectious
disease
studies using several examples and
peer-reviewed journals
that i find to be very relevant to what
we have been studying over the course of
the past several months
with this program that is organized
together with the university of ghana
the gucci memorial institute for medical
research
so as i as already mentioned by vip said
this upcoming omixlogic program
will be one of the components with a
special focus on transcriptomic or
rna-seq data
in other words we will learn how to
analyze next-generation sequencing data
to study
gene mrna expression and that includes
alternative splicing variation and gene
set indentation
and so what we will do in the program is
have
quite a number of different online
training sessions that i will kind of
tell you a little bit more about where
we will both discuss
practice and then apply various aspects
of rnac
data analysis to different types of
project data sets
that we find to be relevant to
infectious disease and immunology of
infectious diseases
specifically we will review methods and
computational environments
where such large next generation
sequencing data can be processed
analyzed and interpreted from a
biological standpoint
and what's important is that we will
touch on some aspects of rna-seq data
that turns this data into an excellent
resource to understand the complexity of
biological regulation
how it is affected by the immune
response to
pathogens and to study these types of
variations at both
tissue and organ bulk rna-seq to get a
snapshot of what's going on
as well as a very detailed understanding
of how differently this process can
take place at the single cell rna-seq
level
and so as you probably know already or
can imagine
one of the major challenges associated
with such big data is just the size
of rna-seq data so rna-seq data sets
from a bulk rna-seq experiment can be
anywhere between 1 and 50 gigabytes
depending on the sample size
and single cell data sets can be even
larger due to the large cell counts
and also large sample size as a result
and so that's why what we do for
all of those that register for this
program is provide you with access
to this t-bioinfo big data analytical
platform
that was developed by the tower
bioinformatics research center
at university of haifa and what
essentially it provides you
is a large disk with a lot of ram
where you can analyze these huge data
sets online
but also i want to show you how the
logic behind analysis
is designed into the interface so that
you can easily deal with large
heterogeneous data sets from multi-omega
studies
in other words applying the
understanding of the logic of analysis
to a variety of different challenges
so the platform includes demo pipelines
as well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
various types of bioinformatic pipelines
that include many
open source scripts packages
as well as proprietary analysis
techniques
relevant to different types of data
different
stages of analysis are performed on
different sections of this multi-omics
platform
and so just to show you how it works and
why we use it in our training programs
as well as research projects let's go
and check out how this platform works
but before we do that let's
uh make sure that everyone has access so
if you could go with me to this link
learn that onyxlogic.com
uh you can register if you don't have an
account
yet and if you register you will
actually get
a free account that you can use
on this platform
okay so if you could go with me to
learn onyxlogic.com
and uh once you get here
you can click on login now this is a
free account
right so this registration is free you
can sign up
with social media or you can sign up
with your email address
and once you sign up you will get a demo
account
on the tbi info platform so i want to
show you but if you want to follow along
you should create this account and
once you're in here you will get an
email notification
and in that email you will find the
details
for the t biome for platform
so as you are registering i am going to
head on over
to the tv info platform and i'll wait
just
a couple more minutes for everybody to
whoever wants to of course to
come to this link so once you are
registered and you will see this in your
email
you will get a link to the server t by
info platform now what is it
it's a bioinformatics platform a server
online on the cloud that you can
log in using the credentials that you
will receive by email
and once you're in here you um we'll
first just get a demo
uh feel for what we're going to be doing
so i'll just guide you
to see how this works and then later on
i'll describe
what are some of the sections that we're
going to be using and covering
in the training so that you both
understand how to apply this
but also can apply it to a project of
your own a data set from
the public domain
all right so i see that a few people
already uh registered
great so if you already have an account
or you are logged in
you'll see your account right here
uh maybe let me know in the chat if
anyone wants me to kind of pause and
wait for them to complete the
registration
um so if i don't see anything i'm just
going to continue
so next generation sequencing data and
you can kind of hover over this section
right here to understand what it is
has revolutionized the way that we
understand
what happens at the subcellular level
because we can take a snapshot
of all of the expressed mrna
here speaking specifically about
transcriptomic data analysis
and one of the first sections that
you'll see right here here is this
section called transcriptomics or
rna-seq chip parallel analysis of ngs
and microarray data and uh instead of
going into this section i'm going to
click on this
uh arrow going down and here you'll see
some demo pipeline so some example
pipelines that we'll just take a look to
get a sense of what this is
once you're here you have this interface
that is organizing various algorithms
that you've probably heard about
into a pipeline builder so this is a
pipeline builder that allows us to
select various methods
of rna-seq data processing
error correction mapping construction of
isoforms
as well as generating a table of
expression
and then analyzing the differences
between biological conditions so let's
just quickly
build a pipeline so you'll see how it
works
so you can click on start every time you
will see a pop-up
that explains what is the logic behind
the steps that we will be doing or that
we have done up until now so for example
here
you can already see an example of a
pipeline that we'll be making
it starts from here then goes into blue
red green and we end the pipeline so
here you have all of these colors
explained
blue is for pre-processing red is for
mapping
and then green is for quantification of
expression levels
and so we'll see how this works when we
build this pipeline so after i select
the first step
now i can continue on to select other
steps that are highlighted
in this dark gray following the example
that i had from the start button i'm
going to click on trimmatic and you will
see
that one of the steps in processing the
reads that come from the sequencer is to
clean them from these adapter sequences
and some bad reads that kind of
degrade the quality of our data overall
so before we start analyzing
let's remove any technical sequences and
variation that is not
needed for our biological interpretation
i'm going to click on
ok another artifact that is common to
these sequencers is what's called
pcr bridge amplification you can see
that step right here
what it essentially does is amplify
the biological material so that we have
enough of it to get a high quality read
signal
however pcr amplification excuse me
does not work in a uniform manner and
has some bias on some sequences and we
can detect that bias
statistically by seeing and
high coverage in very specific sequences
so we can eliminate
this kind of bridge amplification using
pcr by
this additional script called pcr clean
after we have completed this kind of
trimming
we can then proceed to select one of the
mapping algorithms and there's quite a
variety of different mapping algorithms
that might have
a particular benefit for a study
that you might find on public domain
repositories of
next-generation sequencing data like
ncbi and so it's important to understand
both the data that you're dealing with
as well
as the question that you are trying to
ask and
the whole objective of doing what we are
doing today
is to illustrate that this basis
for the selection of algorithms and
building of your pipeline
uh the logic behind the pipelines is
essentially
what you will be getting most from this
program so if you're not familiar with
why we are choosing a particular method
and how this method ties into the
overall objective
of the analysis this is why we will go
through
all of the methods here and kind of
review
some of the considerations behind why or
why not
to use this particular
methodology okay so we finally got to
the step of
generating an expression table so this
is a table of expression
and we have the option to perform
differential gene expression
or we can just end it right here
okay so here you will already see that
some of these are detailed uh
some of these methods are covered in our
detailed online coursework
that we will go through in the program
that i'm speaking about
so here's the demo pipeline right away
you will find here some output files so
if you would like to just
explore what is in these files how did
they get generated what is the
difference between different methods
or different connections that we've made
please go ahead and explore that right
here so again for those
that are just joining the way we got
into this section
is by creating a free account
on learn.onboxlogic.com
and once you have created your account
here you will be able to find
the details of access to this t by info
platform
as well as review some of the course
work
that we will be going through in the
context of this program
okay so as i mentioned
this is one of the challenges is big
data and so in this program you will get
access to these big data tools that will
allow you to analyze rna-seq data
and so first of all we will prepare the
processing pipelines
uh to get the simple gene expression
table or to perform differential gene
expression which
are some standard analytical techniques
typically used in the context of rna-seq
experiments we will also look at ways to
explore these big data sets that contain
thousands of genes in tens or even
hundreds of samples
and what's important is that they can
reveal some important variation between
biological conditions like for example
in this study
you can see principal component analysis
of
three different conditions across two
different types of viruses a virus
this is from stars one so a virus with
or six or a delta or six a mutant
that does not have that gene and so one
of the questions that the authors posed
in the study
is what would be the difference in
disease progression over time
in cell lines and how can we develop
a set of contrasts to start asking the
question in the context of
differential expression and ultimately
for biological interpretation
as you can see in that example it is not
a simple study where you have a
condition and a control
or two different conditions that are
exactly identical in fact what you might
suspect is that there are several
factors at play
maybe it is the type of media that you
are growing your cell lines in
maybe it is the differences between
pathogens maybe it's some kind of a
manufactured uh condition like a
delta uh a mutant virus or something
like that and so
what we will go through is not just
exploratory data analysis and
differential expression but also we'll
look at
some of the ways we can apply regression
to understand
what are some of the relationships and
important factors that contribute to
observed effect in our data for example
we'll talk about
factor regression analysis and what
unsuspected results
it could shed light on when we approach
this data from a data-driven perspective
ultimately though we will talk about
gene set and pathway enrichment so we'll
talk about how
some of these analytical methods can
provide us with
important values to differentiate
between different gene sets
that could be annotated thankfully we
have a lot of
annotated resources especially for human
and mouse animal models
and so we can start
using some of these references to really
understand the biology behind what's
going on so we'll talk about some of the
things that go into
biological interpretation so as i
mentioned
this program rna-seq
data analysis training program will
start
on april 16th and
what's important about this is that we
will
both explore some of the relevant tools
kind of from a theoretical perspective
we'll review some literature that
explains
when and when not to use some of the
tools and what are some of the
considerations when you're building
up your pipeline but we'll also talk
about
how to apply these tools to study
infectious disease
manifestation in different types of
hosts to understand
the intricacies of disease progression
and how we can study the immune
responses
and the manifestation of clinical
phenotypes that we typically associate
with disease so
i think it will be an exciting program
and i'm
hoping that all of you will be able to
join to participate
in the sessions for the training or to
design
and develop your independent project and
i'm sure that beeps will continue
speaking about this
at the end of today's session but before
i pass it back to her i want to briefly
review some of the sessions
that we will have for this program so
beeps if you could please
put the link for the training program
schedule
so if anyone is interested to kind of
get a snapshot an overview
of the different sessions uh what topics
will be covered
as well as what are some of the um
some of the themes that we'll touch on
is going to be
on this link transcriptomics
dot omixlogic.com thank you website
and so you can see here a detailed
overview
with some of the dates when these
sessions will take place they will be
interactive sessions like we are having
now
where you will be able to ask questions
and
practice some of the things that we do
together
so let's review some of those sessions
what do we have planned
um okay let's go through this slide all
right so
it will start on april 16th and we are
posting here the times in uh gmt
uh time zone uh because we are working
together with university of ghana
where many of the participants are
already a part of this
overall training on bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
and hopefully this will be another asset
in their
toolkit to study variable
immune response so we'll start off by
talking about
processing uh transfer atomic data so
we'll talk about
how is this data generated what is in
this data what are we looking for
what is the logic behind what we can do
with this data
and what are some of the steps that we
could consider
depending on what we are trying to
accomplish
in our analysis overall
we'll talk about some of the outputs and
how these outputs could be explored
and we'll see how they are
representative
of the raw data so we'll actually take a
look at what the raw data can reveal
about these observed recorded values
that we obtain in a structured format
we'll then kind of turn to a
session on quantification normalization
and visualization
and here you will get introduced to some
of the tools in r or python
that you could use to quickly explore
using different
aspects of summary statistics and log
normal transformation
to understand variability and how that
variability is representative
of the design behind the data set that
you observe right so somebody
actually took this data and prepared
that data and so what one of the things
that we want to understand is
how can we explore the variation that is
unwanted
technical noise as opposed to how this
data set
could be prepared for downstream
analysis so one of the things that we
will use
in this session are several practical
coding
uh exercises to help us
load data in rn python explore
this data using visualization tools map
this data
onto different types of categorical
values from our sample design
uh we will look at different types of
applications
when we have data that is already
processed or data that is raw and how to
deal with that so
some of that coding experience is
something that you can already go ahead
and try
on learn.onixlogic.com
then we will turn to differential gene
expressions so we'll take a look at
these
popular packages called dc2 and hr
and there we will learn both about the
logic as well as the differences between
these different methods
and how we can use the different values
in these methods to really select
the genes that are helpful for
biological interpretation in other words
which ones are actually different when
we talk about
thousands or even hundreds of thousands
at least tens of thousands of genes
and how do we select the ones that are
most interesting
we'll also look at some examples to
understand what is some of the variation
that we should expect in our data and
how to differentiate between
statistically significant and
insignificant variation for our
downstream interpretation
as i already mentioned we will not only
touch on some of the basic statistical
analysis but we'll also talk about
regression analysis that is a powerful
tool
to understand variation that is not
immediately
obvious and understand how we can
extract
meaningful insights from complex data
sets
biological interpretation is also an art
that you
master as you apply it to a variety of
data sets and so we'll talk about
different ways to annotate
visualize and associate gene expression
data
with biological processes and so we'll
look at
data sets that contain a specific
what's called enrichment of gene sets
and one of the tools that we'll talk
about is what's called
gene set enrichment analysis we'll talk
about
what are some of the methods and
settings for this
analysis and what are some of the
outputs how do we interpret these
outputs
and what we can learn about the
biological processes
and differences in different data sets
that explain
this type of variation now as you know
gene expression is continuous data
and because it's continuous data there
are many tools for unsupervised
and supervised machine learning methods
that are going to be useful
to both explore the data that we have
and understand how this data represents
some of the major trends in the data
that could explain
biology or differences between different
types
of samples that we study or different
groups of samples that we study so we'll
take a look at
how do we apply different clustering
techniques
and how do we use different
dimensionality reduction techniques to
understand such variation
we'll also talk about supervised machine
learning or classification we'll take a
look at some of the commonly used
methods
that could help us deal with large data
sets when we have
very specific uh and maybe not often
statistically significant patterns that
we cannot find
in uh using normal multivariate analysis
methods
so we'll talk about random forests
and how we can perform bootstrapping and
bagging how do we use that to both
identify train but also how to find
specific features that are important for
separation between classes so we'll look
at
feature selection
now what's important in this is that
many programs actually teach
dimensionality reduction and feature
selection from a computer science or a
statistics
kind of point of view where what's
important are
different metrics that allow us to
actually perform the selection
but i think what is important for us
here in the context of the biology
behind these features
is to really understand what are the
specific things that we could be looking
for
to interpret the feature selection
process
and how do we combine our biological
understanding of data sets
with some of these statistical
measurements that we could then use
to automate the process now what's
important today
in any kind of rna-seq discussion is to
talk about single cell rna-seq and so
what we'll do
is we'll talk about the differences
between bulk
and single cell rna-seq it provides us
with
a a very clear picture of what's
happening
at the single cell level but comes with
a variety of challenges that we need to
understand those challenges have to
be addressed at the level of processing
the data
so preparing it for analysis
as well as with the downstream
interpretation of these results because
as you know these are zero inflated data
sets so they have a lot of zeros and so
we're going to be talking about how do
we actually effectively use
some of these annotation techniques to
find
uh yumi uh or umis
and how we can then prepare a meaningful
picture of what is in our single cell
data sets now throughout this program we
will refer to
projects and case study data sets so we
will not be just using
these methods just to understand kind of
the
practical technical aspects of these
methods but we'll look at
examples where these methods have been
applied effectively and so we'll take a
look at some of the
research methods included in
publications
that reveal how these
types of methods are used to understand
infection by
ebola virus by stars 1 and stars 2
viruses
as well as malaria and what you'll find
a lot in this context of the infection
is that we can compare infection
as a result of similar viruses so for
example
we will talk about how other respiratory
viruses
that also cause severe respiratory
disease can compare to source cove2
we'll talk about the immunology what's
called the cytokine storm
both in source cove 2 but also we'll
talk about
ebola which as you know is one of the
pin
and pandemics that was
start of this massive scale next
generation sequencing effort so we'll
learn
some about ebola there as well but we'll
also talk about
how such transcriptomic data is being
utilized
in the context of clinical and
biomedical research
in the context of epidemiology but also
in the context of drug
development so here you can see some
examples of how
network analysis and enrichment analysis
can help us understand
the different types of responses and
targets
ultimately as nodes in those networks
that can help identify
compounds protein protein interactions
and various transmission prevention
techniques
so that we can understand the molecular
drivers or components that
help explain some of those
considerations so after you complete
this program
you will have the opportunity to speak
about
the transcriptomic methods when you read
papers you'll understand those methods
when you explain your own analysis
you'll be confident in knowing how to
explain
why you've chosen a particular method or
what did this method do
and you'll be able to share an example
project either
from one of the projects that we provide
or a project of your own
so that you can have an experience of
applying bioinformatics techniques to
a data set and kind of going through the
full process from the very beginning
of identifying that data set to then
processing the data set preparing it for
analysis and then finally communicating
the
story the biological story behind what
you did
and uh getting feedback on that from the
other participants of the program as
well as from
the experts on our team so
um i hope that all of this uh
answers a lot of the questions that
you've had if you still have some
questions
please do post them in chat i'll be
happy to answer those
and i will pass it back on to beepsaa to
discuss some of the technical aspects of
registration
cost and the details of the different
resources that you will get access to
deepsea over to you
thank you elia so for different parts of
the session uh we will be leveraging the
omex logic resources
to learn about transcriptomics this will
include the asynchronous coursework that
you can find on
learn dot omics logic so
i again yeah sorry so
i do see a couple of questions so let me
just briefly
address uh i see one question so
one of the questions here is how will
this program help in getting employment
um so i just want to briefly mention
that you know we are not
advertising some kind of a you know
career change program but
in general if i can briefly speak about
the trends
in the amount of data that is being
generated by
research centers and labs as well as in
the industry in both clinical
and pharmaceutical and biotechnology
industries you will see that there is a
growing demand
for biologists with computational skills
as well as data scientists that
understand the biology behind the data
so this is such an important trend that
nih the national institute of health
in the us has started a specific program
with a focus on data science
to help train up both biologists and
computational
engineers to understand bioinformatics
and i think this is
evident also if you search anywhere
online people with bioinformatics
degrees
or bioinformatics capabilities are in
high demand
in fact salaries for biologists wet lab
biologists as opposed to
bioinformaticians
also tell the same story so you can get
uh
you know one and a half to two times as
much as a data scientist or a
bioinformatician
as opposed to a lab biologist and so
what's important here i think
and what the employers are really
looking for
isn't necessarily just a degree because
they understand that many students
can go and based on this kind of
obvious trend go for a degree
and get some basic training i think what
employers are looking for is your
ability to think critically about the
data
with an understanding of the methodology
and your ability to apply this
methodology in a correct way
to a real biological challenge and that
is not a trivial thing to demonstrate
but i think one of the best ways that
you can demonstrate that
is by showcasing a project
or even multiple projects that you have
been able to
conduct with the explanation of how
you've used
specific tools and so you know i'm not
going to sell this as a quick fix
you know you want a job as a
bioinformatician this is a program for
you that's probably not the answer
but i would say that this journey into
a career as a bioinformatician starts
from
this kind of an experience where you can
take a data set
and analyze it working with experts and
other
collaborators to get a real impactful
um kind of a project out so that's my
brief uh
answer to that question so i hope i've
answered that uh
based on the chat here thank you pizza
go ahead
thank you so much elia for answering
that question
so as i was again uh mentioning to
everybody so elia has explained very
well
what are the different resources that we
have now again to explain
that once you are creating and login to
this platform so let us start
here together what this will give you
the free level login is also
our demo account so as you see i'm
already using my email id you can also
utilize any of your social login so once
you create an account
you will also be sent an email from dev
at pine.bio
to create account uh to set up your
login details for the server tbio info
platform
so at this free level you can start
exploring some of the free lessons that
are available
and let me take you to the
transcriptomics course
so if you notice here under the
transcriptomics course there are several
different lessons
so if you keep on loading more you will
have different
uh topics that are covered in all of
these lessons here
the three first of the first three of
these lessons as you see
are free lessons any of the lessons
marked with a star
are the lessons that require
subscription anybody who is already
registered
for the program will have access to all
of the lessons which are mentioned here
they do not have to take up subscription
otherwise but if you are interested you
can go ahead and also take subscription
to just these lessons and you can reach
out to me for
those links but similarly not just for
transcriptomics we also have
other courses that the free level on
learn.omics logic will give you access
to
so for example somebody who was
interested in microbiome
data right or learning more about
microbiome so here are some of those
metagenomic
lessons for you that you can go through
the introduction to metagenomics that
will help you get started
in learning about what metagenomics is
and what
is uh you know how to understand this
kind of data and again you will notice
some lessons marked with the star
so in this way we have designed this
page so that at the free level
you are able to get an understanding of
what
bioinformatics is or what are these
different types of
omics data sets so if you are somebody
who is
just getting started with bioinformatics
we definitely
recommend you the introduction to
bioinformatics course
this is a completely free course and
will help you have an understanding of
how bioinformatics is useful in
different domains
like healthcare or research
as well as even in military and other
areas
so please feel free to take this course
and you can explore all these different
projects and courses right here so
you'll find the courses around here
and each of the participants would be
identified
by their email id so as you see here is
my email id
and if i go under here i would be able
to see what are my achievements so far
how many points i've earned what is my
activity on a daily level
so we can see all of these from the
learn omix logic
platform and what i wanted to
also let everybody know is that how to
register
for this entire training
so this is the link that we have for the
training program now
to get started we have already seen that
in this page you will have all the
different dates so we are starting this
friday
which is april 16th with the first
session of this entire one month program
and we will end with single cell rna
seek
on may 20th now let me explain how you
can
register for the program so if you come
to this page you can either click on
pricing or on get started
and you will be given these three
options to register for the program
and i will also explain what these three
options mean
the beginner license gives you access to
the all of these subscription courses
which we have shown here
all the courses marked with a star as
well as
educational access to the tbio info
platform
and also the group session so you will
be able to
take advantage of the full program
start working on a research project or a
research proposal because a project may
not be feasible
in a short period of time in this one
month program
the intermediate license comes with
mentor support which means that if you
are somebody who thinks that you want to
work
with a mentor in addition to the group
sessions we recommend
the mentor support this will come with a
one-on-one
session with your mentor and he or she
will be able to answer any questions
besides the group sessions that you may
have
while the advanced license gives you an
additional 30 days so as you see the
program ends
on may 20th but for anybody who has an
advanced license the program will end
on june 20th you will have an additional
30 days to not only
have a project proposal but also
possibly work on your project
and try to complete it or make it
presentable so that you can
do a poster out of it or present it at
conferences
and or work in your project and make
sure that you know you can take it to
the next step
so these are the three licenses that are
available as part
of the omix logic program the omex logic
transcriptomics program so please feel
free to
explore the licenses and if you have
again
any question here is our email
id so you will be able to reach out to
me anytime you have any question
now let me go back and talk a little
more about
some of the program structures and
objectives
so what we will learn during this entire
one month training is about the
concepts within the immunology of
infection and disease progression which
will include
some topics like central dogma of
molecular
biology immunology of infection
molecular disease markers and stages
host pathogen interaction response
heterogeneity
gene regulation and target pathways
so we will also discuss several
bioinformatics methods such as
processing of ngs data variant calling
quality and processing of rna-seq
pipelines
statistical analysis machine learning
methods such as clustering
principle component analysis
classification as well as
annotation
and once you have already become
familiar with these methods
we will give you the option to first go
through example project so elia has
already explained to you how we'll be
utilizing these example projects and
help you understand
how to work with these kinds of data
sets and then slowly giving you the
opportunity to work
on your own projects as well
so once you complete this training you
will be
able to understand how to do the
following
which is read and understand by
informatics literature
perform basic ngs data analysis
processing steps
analyze data and form hypothesis
prepare data for machine learning cross
check signals with
gene databases know what type of data is
required to answer
scientific questions create your own
bioinformatics analysis and present your
results in an organized way
all of these skills which are very very
essential
in bioinformatics and can also
be translated to other fields
and after achieving the learning
outcomes you would have
learned some of the major best practices
in the field of bioinformatics
you will be exposed to r in python the
two very powerful programming languages
bioinformaticians will need to
understand how to use t
test regression and other tests
analyzing and management of data in
order to communicate
important information which is also an
another best practice in bioinformatics
we'll also touch upon pipeline
development and utilization
and ultimately completing the program
will help you enter the field of
bioinformatics
since you will learn several of these
best practices in bioinformatics and
once someone completes the program this
one month training program
they would be given a certificate of
excellence or certificate of completion
based upon their performance
during this entire one month of training
so yeah
we offer certificates whenever someone
completes a training program
and you already know that if you are
interested in joining the program again
the link is here in the chat box that
will take you to the registration page
so please feel free to complete your
registration here
and we also have these few groups
on linkedin and also
in facebook so let me post the link
again here
in the chat box so that anybody who is
interested
in joining these groups will be able to
go ahead
and join and you can also share with us
any feedback that you have about the
program and the resources
and start taking part in some of the
community discussions that we have
in our groups on social media we are
also
active on instagram you can find us at
buy informatics spine
where we keep on sharing interesting um
images interesting topics interesting
research articles as well as featuring
some of our
bioinformatics community members
so here is the bioinformatics spine
instagram handle if you're interested in
going there and asking us any questions
or if you're interacting with
us there so please feel free to reach
out to us with any questions that you
may have
even after this session and
i want to take a minute here to ask
everybody do you have
any questions or would like to ask us
any questions please feel free to post
them again
in the chat box or to write to me
at marketing at pine.bio and i can help
you
address some of those questions and
again i want to thank everybody for
joining today's webinar
i hope that this was informative for
everybody
and we look forward to seeing you in the
upcoming program
thank you all
thank you everyone